this is world freestyle jetski champion
Daniel Martin and he's about to
demonstrate his incredible aerial jetski
skills
jet skis are pretty heavy and to be able
to pull off a loop fairly moving forward
it's really impressive
so how on earth you get a 220-pound Jets
me to perform a backflip
the first thing Daniel does is
accelerate really fast so that he can
create waves underneath the jetski
and then he uses one of these waves to
launch himself into the air so
essentially he's created a wavy ramp and
that starts the jetski tipping over at
the same time he also uses his own
weight being thrown back to pull it he
angles the handlebars and he can control
the angle of the Jets at the back of the
jetski and so he tilts those give him
the extra push and start the whole thing
turning over and once he's in the air
he's at the mercy of gravity which means
he's got at most one second to deal with
he has to make sure that before he
leaves he has enough speed is the
absolute critical factor he has to be
traveling at least thirty kilometers per
hour or eighteen miles per hour to have
any chance of doing a full rotation
thank you experts that's just the
vineyard science